>> Okay. It's my honor today
to introduce Susan Athey.
She's the Economics of Technology
Professor at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business.
Susan received her
bachelor's degree
from Duke and her
PhD at Stanford,
and not to be outdone by that,
Duke gave her an honorary
PhD degree, or a doctorate.
Susan's research focuses
on the intersection
of machine learning
and econometrics,
marketplace design, and the
economics of digitization.
She advices governments and
businesses on marketplace design
and platform economics.
I remember when we
first heard of her and met
her when she came in as,
in 2007 or so, as
Microsoft's Chief Economist,
you call it Consulting
Chief Economist.
As a preview of the forthcoming
fireside chat which
was this time today
featured early,
filmed earlier than
the distinguished lecture,
Susan mentioned that
Steve Balm at the time said,
he was just having,
was interested in
learning more about
this online stuff
and you'll hear more
about that when you
see the fireside chat.
Susan was elected to
the National Academy
of Science in 2012,
and the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences in 2008.
She's taught in
the economics departments
at MIT, Stanford, and Harvard.
In 2007, Susan was
awarded the James John
Bates Clark Medal.
This is known as
the Nobel Prize for
younger economists and in
this case under 40 and yeah,
I guess you're still
under 40, which is great.
>> Exactly, [inaudible]
>> Today, she'll be speaking
about large-scale models of
consumer choice and
counterfactual inference.
A really interesting
area and with
implications not
just for services,
but for core econometric models
and even Biology I
think so. Take it away.
>> Great. Thanks so much.
So, I'm delighted to be here at
MSR and really it's
wonderful to be back
and see old friends and
particularly people
who really introduced me to
this whole research agenda.
So, my relationship with
Microsoft started in 2007,
and I was brought in at
that point because I knew
things about marketplace
design and auctions,
and Microsoft realized that they
just built up the search engine
and they were trying,
they really hadn't started
optimizing the ad platform
for the search engine at all,
and they also had a lot
of strategic questions
about how to compete
with Google and so on.
So, I came in but I
had no experience
with working with companies,
or with engineering.
I didn't know what
machine learning
meant and I had never worked
with large-scale systems.
In some sense I was a baby
along with Bing Ads,
because at the time
I came in in order
to analyze the data
from Bing Ads,
which at that point
we called adCenter,
you actually had to take up a PC,
there is a woman named
Triza Nong and she had to take
a PC and spend
the entire weekend copying
the files onto a hard drive,
which they then FedExed to me
in New England and then
I worked with that data.
So, I actually provided some of
the first insights about Bing Ads
because I was the first one
who could actually
break the data into deciles,
or centiles, because actually
the computing
infrastructure didn't
exist there to actually do that.
So, we grew up
alongside the building,
the infrastructure,
to optimize the system and it was
really exciting to be
there in those early days,
when everything was
new and every insight
you brought from
data could really
be put into great action.
So, in those early days,
I was thinking that what
I could bring to bear
was things about economics
and advertiser behavior,
because a lot of the engineers
who had brought them
brought in came from other
products and Microsoft.
So, there was
this big order database
where people put their bids
for search auctions,
but there was no real reason
you had to think about those
as active participants,
because the database
was just sitting there.
So, it's easy to obstruct
away from you and the idea
that you had customers.
So, I was trying to bring
in economic ideas there.
I would say things
like, ''Hey guys,
if we reduce
the quality of the ads,
or if we raise the prices,
the advertisers might
not buy as much."
There would be a little bit
of a pushback,
like, well where's
the evidence for that?
Actually it turned out, in
some sense it's not
true because if
the order database is
fixed and you query it,
the order database won't
change instantaneously.
So, you had to think about
different forms of
analytics as well as
different ways to experiment to
really get it that
advertiser behavior.
So, as I started trying
to dig into this,
I started realizing
that although I had
great insights about how to do
empirical analysis on
small data sets from economics,
there was so much that I really
was not prepared to do with
these larger datasets.
Being one economist in a team of,
all the engineers were coming
from engineering disciplines,
and I saw people who I was
able to collaborate with,
all coming from computer
science disciplines.
In order to do
these empirical projects
I really needed to
become bilingual.
So, that was
an amazing experience
for me and actually,
Patrice is here,
we had these early
arguments where
we really we're clashing,
and there's a sense of
like, I'm an economist,
I'm like I've been doing
empirical work my whole life,
of course I know how to do this.
Patrice like, well,
we've been doing
machine learning, we
know how to do this.
The conversations where I
figured out where we
were miscommunicating,
where I wasn't understanding
where other people
were coming from,
were really enlightening for me.
I actually, I still think about
Patrice all the time
because when I go out
and give seminars to
machine learning crowds,
I harken back to
the way that I first
crystallized how to explain
why what I was doing
or think that way,
I was thinking that was
a little bit different.
Then at the same time,
I really shifted
my career a lot in
the last six or seven years to
try to bring machine
learning into economics.
So, I feel like there's actually
this really exciting marrying
of two disciplines.
Both its transformative
to economics but
also there were a few things
that we did know
along the way that were useful
and can also be embedded
in machine learning.
Now, there's some of you
here to which this is
not new because one of
the few places that
really has a great
concentration of people
bringing together
machine-learning and
causal inference is Microsoft.
We have it among some of the
economists from Greg Louis,
in New England and Matt Tatty,
work that he did while he
was here on project Alice.
Of course [inaudible] is here
and we've had people come
through like Leon Batu,
who is someone that we
thought a lot about
counterfactual reasoning and
adCenter with and so on.
So, and of course a lot
of the work in the New York
Lab on contextual bandits
also is very solidly in
the causal inference framework.
So, when I generalize
about machine learning and if
I slip anywhere along the way,
just let me make
sure to start with,
I'm carving out that elite.
Brilliant group of exceptions
that is bringing
these things together.
When I'm generalizing, I'm
thinking more about like
the broad world of image
recognition with neural nets.
So, just to not offend anyone.
I realized that not
everybody doing
machine learning is
only doing that.
Okay. So, with
all of that a precursor,
I want to talk about
a line of research.
Today, I will talk
about a line of
research I've been working
on with David Blei,
who many of you know is a
computer scientist at Colombia,
whose goal is really to bring
together econometric models
with Bayesian
probabilistic models
to do counterfactual inference.
Before I dive into that,
I'll mention that,
and I have two strands
of this machine learning and
causal inference literature,
that most of my presentations and
machine learning audiences have
focus on the other strand,
which is more about
estimating heterogeneous
treatment effects,
building things into
AB testing platform,
personalized policy
evaluation, and recently,
I've been thinking about
contextual bandits as well.
So, that is one, I think,
and a very easy place where
machine learning and
causal inference come together.
Because personalized
prediction and
personalized treatment effects
are very close.
Now, if you're not smart,
you can get wildly wrong answers
when you make that leap.
But if you're
a little bit clever and
you incorporate
some basic insights,
then you can modify
the techniques pretty,
not too hard and
get personalized treatment
effects and so on.
So, that is one line,
and I'm very excited about
that line and of course,
MRA and others here are part of
that broader literature as
well as other folks in New York.
This second line, is
fitting them with
a different branch of economics,
which we would call
a structural modeling,
and this branch more naturally
connects with people who
build probabilistic models.
Because we're writing down
generative models of
how the world works,
and I would say
the difference between
the economist and the
non-economists Bayesian,
would be that the economists
are going to take a little
bit more seriously the idea
that we're estimating
preferences.
We're estimating a
consumer's preferences.
Therefore, we're really getting
something fundamental or
structural about a person
or about a firm,
so that we can take them
to new environments.
But we have more complicated
applications of that.
Auctions is one that I've
spent a lot of time on,
where I assume that bidders
are maximizing profits,
and they're playing equilibria.
Those are more, I would
a stronger assumption, stronger
behavioral assumptions.
If you make those assumptions,
you can say things.
The one I'm talking about today,
all I'm going to be assuming,
that consumers choose
what's best for them.
So, it's a fairly weak
behavioral assumption.
But nonetheless, those
assumptions can be
used to do counterfactual
inferences.
So, just that's how
this all fits in.
So, I'm going to be fitting into
a strand of the economics
literature that
you guys might not
see as much unless
you've been listening to
Matt Tatty and Greg Louis.
Okay. So, just to say that
the class of datasets that
we're working with here,
are we call in economics panel
or longitudinal datasets,
where we're seeing a bunch
of units over time.
So, example datasets of course,
one of the things that
inspired this work,
was work I was doing on
news using Microsoft data.
You might have a set
of users and see
the news articles they
viewed or the websites
they viewed.
One of the datasets
I'm going to look at
today, is GPS data.
So, I've got device ID for
millions of people and
then I have a sequence of
timestamp latitudes
and longitudes.
That's the first dataset
I'll talk about today.
Another dataset that I'm
starting to work with
would be consumer
credit card transactions,
where you see again
the consumer ID
and the timestamp and the
location and the amount
of the charge.
Another dataset I'll look
at today, is shopping data.
So, you see the consumer
ID and what they bought.
So, the counterfactual
questions that we
might think about are
in the new setting.
We might say, well, how will
users change their
consumption of news,
if for example
Google News shuts down?
Markus Mobius, who's
in MSR New England,
and I wrote a paper about that,
where Google News
shut down in Spain.
So, we tried to make
predictions about,
in this case, what
they would've done if
Google News had not shut down.
That's a counterfactual,
though we might actually have
an actual event and then
we can verify our results.
How do physical movements
of consumers change?
If say, they say lose a job,
or the one I'm going to focus on,
is what happens if a
store opens and closes?
How is that consumers
are going to
change their shopping patterns?
So, one thing I want to work on
the future's like
the retail apocalypse.
So, we see some of
these chain stores closing
and what does that do to
consumer shopping behavior.
Various other things,
what products make
good loss-leaders,
like what if the supermarkets
going to to put
something on sale,
what would be good
products to put on
sale to attract people into
the store and to attract
particular types of
people into the store?
So, the common features are that,
we have some structured data
about the objects.
In some cases, we'll have prices.
But I'm generally going to be
thinking about things where I
don't have a lot of structured
data about the objects.
The consumers consume maybe
a wide variety of products,
and I want to understand
their choices.
So, this is roughly
related to the recommendation
system problem,
which you guys have
all studied a lot.
One approach to that,
is a matrix
factorization approach.
So, we can think about
a matrix of movies and users,
and we're going to
try to come up with,
say of a factor structure,
we can represent this matrix as
a d-dimensional latent
user preferences
for characteristics of movies.
There's a d-dimensional
latent vector which
describes the characteristics
of the movies,
and I can predict the user's
preference for the movies
by multiplying
those two matrices together.
Broadly, this is
answering the question,
what types of things
do users like?
Of course, I know and
I'm very well aware
that there are lots of extensions
and generalizations of this,
but just high level,this
simple matrix
factorization can predict
what things they like.
Of course, if you think about
from the perspective of
Amazon or a company like that,
doing this type of analysis
can be very simple.
You can take the whole year's
worth of Amazon purchases
and just boil it
down to a matrix.
You're going to be losing
a lot of information though,
when you boil that down
because you might be thrown
away information about
what did the consumer
buy together?
Like maybe they bought hot dogs,
and hot dog buns together
and I'll come back to that.
That says something that's
more interesting that
they bought them
together than if they
bought them at different
times during the year.
Maybe the product was
on sale when they
bought that product.
So, the reason they
bought that product, is
because it was on sale.
Maybe the reason
that they didn't buy
a product was that's I
never showed it to them.
My existing recommendation
system just didn't
recommend this type of
product to this consumer.
So, while this approach
is very helpful,
if you start from here of
course it's completely
impossible to answer questions
about what would happen
if I change prices.
Because you're not
really modeling
why they bought
things to start with.
The economics and marketing
literatures and there's basically
part of marketing that basically,
is economics that we've
like computer science.
We tend to invade and
adjacent disciplines
and take them over.
So, that's one of
the subjects of our invasion.
So, we would typically build
a functional form model
of the user utility,
and estimate preferences based
on the user choice behavior.
But this literature which
like Daniel McFadden won
a Nobel Prize for his work
on this in 1971 and 1972,
so, this is
a very old literature,
there he was modeling
the extension of the bark.
So, he was modeling consumers
transportation choices.
But same kind of setting,
one product at the time like
different brands of yogurt,
we typically have very simple
models like we have
a single product
specific latent variable
which we might think
of as product quality.
Typically, in the old
days we didn't
have micro-consumer data and
so what we worried about was that
that might be
correlated with price.
So, we might worry that,
if we just had
a single dataset with
with constant prices
and the dataset, then,
we don't know if
people are not buying
this product because it has
a high price or if it's
because it has low quality,
and we might expect
generally the higher
quality products
have higher prices.
So, if we compare
a cross product,
say here's a low price product
and here's a high price product,
that's not going to tell us
anything about what would
happen if a single product
changed its price.
So, people were
very worried about
this latent variable of
product quality that was
correlated with price.
So, they spent a lot of time
trying to think about things
that would shock prices
like cosh shocks and so on,
that would move prices as
a natural experiment and using
that to try to learn about
the effects of price,
but usually from aggregate data.
Now, as we went along,
we got more of this shock like
your scanner data
where we would see
the same consumers over time
and we would see the prices that
individual consumers saw
when they visited the store.
So, then it's
actually much easier
to try to understand
the causal effect of
price because I might
see two essentially
identical consumers,
one comes in on Tuesday,
one comes in on
Wednesday the price goes
down on Wednesday and
they buy on Wednesday
and not on Tuesday.
So, roughly it's not
completely exogenous
variation but
if you control for enough stuff,
the idea is that you
can think of whether you
came in on Tuesday or
Wednesday before
the price change or after
as good as random,
and so that type of price
variation can then be used to
understand the effect
of price in a way
that's much harder to
do an aggregate data.
Then, what this
literature did is it
actually stack with
this one product
at a time thing but it
actually went off
in a whole bunch
of other directions which
actually relate now to
the inverse reinforcement
learning literature.
They would basically assume,
suppose this consumer is solving
a dynamic programming problem
and they're stockpiling
laundry detergent.
So one of my PhD students wrote
their whole thesis on well,
one was stockpiling laundry
detergent another was like
experimentation versus habit
formation in laundry detergent.
So, we're modeling
all these consumers
solving dynamic
programming problems while
estimating the value function and
inferring their dynamic
preferences from that.
So, that literature we went to a
very I would say
structural direction,
this was sort of controversial
because people didn't like
all the assumptions
and like why is it
habit formation here
and stockpiling there?
Why are you stockpiling in
this way and not in that way?
So, it was controversial
because of all the assumptions
but that's sort of
the direction the literature went
in which is a very
different direction
than we think about
these big recommendation
system models
where you're looking
at lots of products.
One product at time misses
many aspects of consumer choice,
for example, actually if you
ask like safe, I'm sorry.
An unnamed grocery store
gave you this data
actually back in the early 2000's
and the grocery store
actually the problem they
came to was they said,
"I want to understand how
to segment my consumers,
and I want to understand
how to give them coupons,
and how to do these price
promotions and discounts."
But they were thinking
about like store-to-store
competition.
They were thinking that I want
to get the consumers into
the store and see and they
would buy other things.
So, those types of questions
are really not answered
by just studying yoghurt.
In your studying yoghurt,
you can understand the effect of
coupons or something or TV ads
but it's hard to understand
the things that are
interesting to a store.
Organizing the store and so on.
Then in the online space,
there's sort of the online
version of shelf space.
So, what should I show consumers?
What should I recommend
to them on the page?
What kinds of discounts
would get what,
if I email them a discount offer
what's going to get them
to come to my website,
but if they come to my website
they're going to
buy other things.
So there are some of my
colleagues did some work at eBay,
where they sort of
found that when
eBay sort of made
changes that made it
cheaper for sellers
to listings on eBay,
in fact those sellers
bought stuff when
they came to eBay,
and so just getting the sellers
to come to eBay increased
their revenue because the sellers
bought stuff while they
were on the store.
So, the spillover effect
is very big,
and Marks and Matrice for
member back in the eBay used
to put a lot of spam ads on Bing
and part of that is
because if you could
just get that
consumer to click and
come to eBay even if
the ad had nothing to
do with the query,
maybe they'd buy something.
So, this idea of
getting people into
the store matters for that.
So, what we're going to do in
this line of research is we're
going to try to bring in
matrix factorization and
embedding Tet methods from
CS and we're going to
use a Bayesian approach,
it doesn't have to
be Bayesian but
we liked it for a
variety of reasons.
We get flexibility in
incorporating the structure.
We can also represent
the uncertainty that for
some consumers we
don't really know very
much and for other
consumers we know more,
and we can ensure using
priors that the consumers
if we don't know
very much we can learn
using hierarchical priors.
So, we're going to pay,
we're going to estimate an
economic style structural model
using computational techniques
from Machine Learning,
and we're going to be paying
particular attention
to identification.
So, identification is
the economics jargon for,
can you really learn
something from this?
Like is there
actually variation in
prices and helps you
learn that and also,
we're going tune our models
along counterfactuals.
So, we're going to try to
select models that do well on
counterfactuals
rather than models
that do well in
freight prediction.
So, I'll try to flesh that out.
I would say generally though,
that is a theme that
I think can be taken
away to the machine
learning people,
maybe in socially, the
canonical Machine Learning,
we often just think okay,
we want to predict well,
we're going to look
at goodness of fit.
This mean squared
error log likelihood,
but if what you're actually
going to do is think about
changing a price than instead
of tuning the model
for goodness of fit.
I should hold out some
price changes and see
how well I do with these kind
of counterfactual exercises,
and so those types of getting
the right optimization,
the right objective function
can really make a difference.
So, there's two ways
you can use this.
We can use it the way we
do in economics normally,
but if I think about
at a large scale,
it can also be
a pre-processing step.
So, we might be able to take,
they're going to be
some scaling issues with this.
So, I might be able
to learn some things
about the latent
variable structure
from a model like this,
and then embed it
in a model that's maybe
simpler to compute.
So, that's also something
I would think in
and could be useful in
tech firms as well.
Okay. So, basically
we're going to apply
these large scale
latent variable approaches with
multiple observed
product characteristics
and we're going to consider
lots of products at once,
and as we go along,
I'm going to talk about
distinguishing correlation
from complementarity,
testing assumptions and so on.
Let me actually jump into
the first paper now.
So, the first paper of this
came out in the papers and
proceedings in May of the
American Economic Association,
and so, this paper,
I'm actually going in reverse
order chronologically.
This is the last paper we wrote,
the last paper we began,
but it's the simplest
in some ways.
So I'm going to start there and
then get more complicated.
So, here from the
counterfactual questions
are questions like: Where's
should a restaurant be located?
What's the best type of
restaurant for a location?
Who are restaurants competitors?
How far will a consumer travel
to a restaurant they like?
I would say, these
are examples of sort
of product design location and
quality questions
and there's lots of
analogs to these questions
that firms would make.
So if you were thinking
about surface,
how many skew should
there be in surface?
Or how many versions of
sequel should we offer?
Questions like that
they would sort of fit
into this type of
a framework as well.
So, we're going to start
because we have got
computer science
colleagues have gotten
nice little acronyms
for all of my model.
So, we call this the Travel Time
Factorization Model
of user choice.
But in the economics framework,
we start by writing
down a utility.
That's just the
convention we have.
So, it's going to map
into a probabilistic
model like one for one,
but we usually just start
by writing down utility.
So, we say the user's utility
has these components.
There's a popularity component
for item i, for restaurant i.
Then there's the
consumer preferences
which are a product
of latent factors.
So, this user u has a vector
of latent preferences and
a restaurant i is going to
have a vector of latent factors.
Then this is the part
that gets a little
more I would say,
structural although it's I
mean I don't want to
glorify it too much,
it's just that we're doing
sort of tuning on the model here.
We're going to say that
you're going to care about
the distance between
user u item i.
So, this covariate varies
at the user item level,
and we're gong to put
it in a log format
because there's sort of
some concavity we
think with distance,
and then we're going to
factorize the coefficients.
So, we're going to say
that there's a user
items specific preference
for distance,
but that's going to be
represented in latent factors.
So, what that's going to
allow us to say is that;
I'm not willing to travel
very far for coffee,
but I am willing to
travel for good food.
So, if you think about it
like, so we're going
to find later,
is that people are willing
to travel farther in
the Bay area for like
Asian restaurants
but they don't travel for coffee.
But of course there's
lots of restaurants.
So, I I can't possibly
learn my user
items specific preference
at that level.
So again, my factorizing it,
I can figure out there are
types of restaurants that
users are willing to drive to
and types that they're not.
Then there's a time
varying effect which could
capture that maybe some
restaurants are
good when it rains,
and some restaurants
are good when it
doesn't rain or
different times of
year with students, and
then we have noise.
Then, we have
a hierarchical Bayesian
models they're going to affect
the mean of the prior of
these different things.
So, we have say a 160
restaurant types,
we can't learn
each user's preference for
160 things because the users
only go to like 12 restaurants,
but I can learn that
the latent vector for
Japanese restaurants is similar
to that for Chinese restaurants,
and that's going to go into the
hierarchical prior on the Alphas.
So, this is the way we would
write it in economics,
and it turns out that it's fairly
straightforward to show that
if the consumer is just
choosing the maximum of those,
if you assume that the consumer
choose the maximum of those,
then the probability
that user U and time T
chooses item I is
this multinomial logit format.
So, yeah.
>> For that to continue with
an assumption on
the noises distribution?
>> Yes. Exactly so the error
needs to be a logit error,
it needs to be extreme value,
type one extreme value error.
>> Okay.
>> So, if it's a type
one extreme value error
then we get this functional form.
So, of course in
machine learning you would
have just said it starting,
and so I'm going to write down
a multinomial logit
probabilistic model.
In economics we just say well,
it's convenient to know
that if a consumer is
maximizing utility and
their utility looks like this,
then the parameters
you learned from doing
this estimation are actually
the perimeters of
their utility function.
Then you say well,
why do I care?
Well, if you're going
to predict in the same
environment you don't care.
Right? If the environment
is stable then you don't
need to care why the
consumer did what they did,
all you need to know
is what they did.
But if I change the
distance or if I make
a particular restaurant
unavailable or if something,
if I put a different
restaurant in
the same location,
things like that,
then I need to think
about why the consumer
liked what they did in order
to infer their choices.
So, the way that we've typically
done this in economics,
there's a few people who
do this but this isn't,
usually this is done with price.
Then the second two papers
we're going to focus
on price but here it's
distance that we're
learning the effective.
Okay. So, then this
is part of what Dan McFadden
got the Nobel Prize for,
now this might seem, this
is not terribly deep,
this was also the early 1970s.
He then developed a series of
extensions of these models
and looked at
their properties as well.
One is called the nested
logit which I'll
come back to later,
which he also popularized.
Okay. So, then in this paper,
this is written to economists,
so I'm going to compare for
the economist's perspective to
a simple multinomial
logit comparison
which is what the economists
would normally have done,
is they would not have
this factorization
and they wouldn't
have these complicated factors.
Instead, they would just have
a constant price effect.
Or if they'd use
a much more sophisticated
framework there might be,
you might have
only five choices and
then there would be
a a user but not item,
just a user specific
coefficient on price.
That we call, we call that a
random coefficients model.
So, this model is
different from the
traditional economic models
and we have a lot more items
and we're factorizing them. Yeah.
>> Should we think of
the price effect going into
the customer
preferences component
in this particular model?
>> Yes. In the
restaurants because we
don't have price variation,
this is an
identification problem.
I can't really tell why you like
a restaurant if the restaurant
never changes its price.
Now what I can learn
is I actually have
the Yelp price
categories in there,
and I treat that as
an observable characteristics.
So, I can learn
those characteristics but
I wouldn't completely
hang my hat on that.
In the sensitive
Chinese restaurants are
always in the $3 sign,
and Mexican are always
in the $2 sign,
I can't really tell
the difference between is this
because it's Chinese or
because it's expensive.
I can't tell that. So,
we don't put a lot,
we would say in accounts we
don't put a structural
interpretation or
we don't put a
causal interpretation on
it because we don't
have variation in it.
There's a little bit
of that problem with
distance as well
but because I have
this same variable I
can measure across
different restaurants I
feel more comfortable.
Although I would say that
the criticism from the
economists would be,
how do you really know
that you're not willing
to travel the Chinese and
you just don't like Chinese?
So, there's a bit of
a problem, it's not perfectly,
it's not the best application
of a causal estimate.
Okay. So, the data,
it comes from SafeGraph,
which is a company
that aggregates
locational information
from consumers
who've opted into
sharing their location
through mobile applications.
So, you accept, when you install
the mobile application to
have your data shared this is
aggregated anonymously
and then securely,
researchers are able
to do research on
that data and with
some aggregations and
anonymizations implicit there.
We're going to study
January through October,
2017 in the Bay Area.
So, part of the reason
we've picked
lunch restaurants is that if you
think about location data,
it's hard to tell exactly what
a consumer is doing
by where they are
but if I see you
at a restaurant at
lunchtime I know
what you're doing.
So, another example would
be if I see you at a park,
or if I see you at
a movie theatre,
a grocery store.
So, the're some things that
are very well revealed by
location data and restaurants
is one of them. [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> What does SafeGraph do to
protect [inaudible]? How
does it it, at does it do?
>> Well, first of
all it never knows
any PII for the consumer.
So, it's always, it's
just linked by device ID,
and then there's geographic
fuzziness around it to.
>> [inaudible] some K notion of
anonymity [inaudible] as well.
>> Yes. But I mean,
so this data is
not released to the public.
So, we also are
signing non-disclosure
agreements and the data's
protected just like data
inside of tech companies
is protected.
So yeah, it's not
anonymized to the extent that
I would post it on the web.
So, maybe that would
be okay but it hasn't they
haven't intended it to
be done that way, yeah.
So, then what we do is we
construct the typical morning
location of the consumer,
just when is the most
common place to consumer is
found between 9:00 and 11:15 AM.
we throw out a lot
of people that don't
have consistent
morning locations.
So, we actually throw out
quite a lot of people,
as we narrow down to people
for whom we can do
the study well.
So, we've just taken
a selected sample of people
that we can understand
their behavior very well.
They have to have most
of their morning pings
in their morning location,
this paper we're just doing
like the west side of the bay,
down through the Silicon
Valley to San Jose.
We're going to call
a lunch restaurant visit
is if we observed
at least two pings more than
three minutes apart
between 11:30AM and 1:30 PM.
This also really kills
us because a lot of,
we don't have a ton of
pings and so a lot of
people ping once but
they could have just
been walking by.
So, with more work we could
try to do more to get
more pings back in but
we just stuck with this.
Then the restaurants were
identified using data that
Yelp provided us that
uses geo-coordinates,
star ratings, price range,
as well as the restaurant
opening and closing times.
So, in our data we have,
per user we have about 12
visits per user and
again this is the selected sample
of users that had
plenty of visits.
They visited seven
distinct restaurants,
so just because I
see the user I don't
exactly know where
they're going to go next.
Each restaurant is in
multiple Yelp categories,
so they actually visited
more than seven
distinct categories.
They went on a median distance
of three miles to
the restaurants,
so actually traveling a little
farther than I thought they
would, and so on.
From the restaurant perspective,
the restaurants, the
data's kind of sparse.
Once we narrow down
to a small user base,
then we're not going to have
a lot of visits per restaurant.
So, our restaurants only
get about 14 visits per
restaurant and so on.
Okay. So, then the estimation,
we do Bayesian estimation
with a hierarchical prior.
There's a Gaussian prior over
the latent characteristics
which are shifted
by the observed covariates
like the ratings and
the price categories,
and the restaurant types.
Then we estimate the coefficients
on those characteristics,
these matrices H. We use
mean-field variational inference
to approximate the posterior.
We're using independent
Gaussians and we
find the parameters that
minimize the distance.
It's yet to be seen how
much people are going to
hate this in economics,
because we have typically used
Markov chain Monte Carlo
in economics,
and people have felt
strongly about this type
of approximation has
not been sort of,
I would say accepted yet.
I'm testing the waters by
putting it out there and so,
we will see how much
people complain about it,
but I think my response
to that is, historically,
economists thought about as,
we were going to
write down a model,
we were going to say the God of
economics gave us the model.
We were going to get
all the functional forms,
and we were going to get it
sort of perfectly right,
and then we're
going to do sort of
theories is going to tell us,
and statistical theory
will tell us if it's right
and will get confidence
intervals and standard errors.
While the machine learning
perspective is a little more,
we're going to hold out
test data and see if it works.
Now, that's not as helpful
for counter-factual imprints.
But so, what we're
going to try to
do is find datasets that have
lots and lots of experiments in
them or natural experiments,
so that we can hold out test data
of experiments and see
if it works and then
that will hopefully
convince the people who
were used to having theorems that
say that they're getting
the right answer.
Because if you're approximating
the posterior with
independent Gaussians,
obviously you're not
getting the right answer.
So, I can't prove
a theorem that says that I
am but it works well enough.
Okay. So, in terms of
Model Fit, so again,
you guys probably are
less interested in
this really kind of stupid
multinomial benchmark.
Stupid in the sense
it doesn't have
a lot of parameters
and heterogeneity,
this is again, more
of a benchmark
up against the classic
economics approach.
So, I'll just show you our
model in the test sample.
We get our precision at
one is about 20 percent,
our precision at
five is 35 percent,
and at 10 is 42 percent.
So, we're doing
a reasonably good job
of predicting what
users are choosing.
We break out our goodness of
fit in a variety of ways,
to show basically how this
works with user deciles.
So, here's an example
in the test set,
the precision at one is
going to be much higher for
the 10th decile of
user restaurant consumption.
The users who use a lot were much
better and so the model
is able to adapt to
the more frequent users and
learn their preferences
better and same with restaurants.
Restaurants are more popular,
we're able to also predict
those better and so on.
This picture we're looking
at how we do in terms of
fitting the how distance
relates to the visit probability.
So, the actual relationship
is here in red,
so this is the
visit probabilities
of a function of
the user's distance
for the restaurant and we
see that actually in
this aggregate way,
both the simple
multinomial logit and
the personalized TTFM
multinomial logit
both fit the shape pretty well.
So, actually one insight is that,
actually we are talking
about this earlier
with some colleagues
here is that,
whether you want a complicated
machine learning model
or a complicated
personalize model
depends on the question
you're asking,
and if you're just want to
ask a simple question like
how does distance from users
on average relate to probability,
then actually a simple model
can do that on average
and it's a little less bumpy
than my complicated model.
But if you want to ask how
will this user respond,
then of course you need
a more personalized models.
So, in some sense
if we were tuning
for just this kind of
aggregate prediction,
we should throw away all the
latent variables and choose
a very simple model but if
I'm tuning for personalization,
then I should use
a more complex model.
I pause on that,
because actually a lot
of economic questions
actually are a little bit
more aggregate.
I might be raising a price
for a segment of consumers,
or making an offer for
a group of consumers,
and then you don't necessarily
want full personalization.
Okay. Then let me now show you
just a few of the results.
So, first of all, we
compute elasticity,
so elasticity is how
a percentage change in X
leads to a percentage
change in Y,
so now we're looking
at how does a
percentage change
in distance lead
to a percentage change
in visit probability.
So, these elasticities,
they're negative because there's
some things farther away,
you're less likely
to visit and we can
see here just ranking Mexican,
you're very sensitive
to distance, while say,
Chinese and Japanese you're
less sensitive to distance.
Your more sensitive, we
don't actually have a lot
of price range threes
and fours at lunch,
so mostly the one versus
two is where we have data.
So, you're less
willing to travel for
cheaper restaurants and you're
less willing to travel for
low rated restaurants. Yeah.
>> Will that be
explained by variability
within each category?
>> So, how would you
actually distinguish this?
Yeah, so basically, the way that
we would tease these
apart would be,
there's some Chinese
restaurants that
are in one versus two.
But as I mentioned earlier,
we don't have experimental
variation in this stuff,
so I wouldn't interpret
these completely.
I wouldn't go out and make
business decisions based on
these results but I would say
that there's sort of descriptive.
These are getting estimated as
turns of the loadings
on these variables
and the hierarchical prior. Yeah.
>> So, the previous plots
I interpreted
those as just you set up
this ranking problem
where your way to rank
whether utilities
predictive by a model.
>> Yeah.
>> Then check the position
at one position.
>> Yeah.
>> But I wasn't sure that
the model as stated was
actually identified like that,
you couldn't pin down
the parameters of
that model to within
Epsilon of the ground
truth parameters if
the users were actually behaving
according to that model.
So, I don't know what to
make of these numbers,
like it could well be that,
I could come up with
two alternative
explanations that just
my optimizations happen to
pick one of those two date.
>> Yes, so I would say here
the identification is
less clean and as I
said you could find
another way to fit
that would load up
more on some of
these factors and not on others.
I'm going to show you in
a minute the way that we try to
test it with restaurants
opening and closing,
but this dataset was too small,
so we didn't have
sufficient power.
So, I'm going to move next
to the supermarket data,
where I have like thousands
of price changes and there,
it's cleaner to sort
of pick that out.
So, I think that the thing
on the distance though,
is in some sense I'm seeing,
I'm kind of generalizing
a little bit.
There are some some extrapolation
assumptions basically,
that I'm assuming that these,
if I'm seeing users who
have different choice sets,
then I can infer something
about distance and
also the fact that I'm
seeing this user go to
lots of different restaurants.
But I am relying at some level on
functional form assumptions
to tease out how to
attribute things to distance
versus Chinese versus price.
So, I'm learning that partly by
looking across users. Yeah.
>> One thing for
the highest quintile that users,
I mean that L last seems
to like drop down here?
>> Yeah. That's,
it's a little weird.
I don't know about that one.
With the price range, we
don't have any data but here,
again this could be
an cautionary tale that
you shouldn't interpret
that structurally.
Okay. So, we also look at
differences across cities,
and we see that
there're some cities
where people are willing
to travel far and
these tend to be the ones where
things are farther apart.
While there're less
willing to travel in
some of the denser cities.
Then, we look at how the
model predictions for
the effects of restaurant
openings and closings
controlling for other changes.
So, we look at if a
restaurant closed,
what is the impact on
the typical restaurant
within two miles,
two to four miles, four
to six miles, and so on.
So, this model basically tells us
how the impact of
the restaurant opening
and closing is distributed.
So, another problem with
this application as it is now,
and so I'm like,
by the way you've probably
figured out by now I
don't like go to town
defending my papers.
So, I'm telling you
their strengths and weaknesses.
But we're trying to extend
this in a variety of ways.
The thing that actually varies
in the data as we do see
restaurants opening and
closing, but each restaurant.
There's so many restaurants
that each restaurant has
only this very tiny impact on
the restaurants around it.
So, you need a lot of data
to actually pin this down.
So, in particular here,
these are the actual impacts
from the restaurants.
We have several 100 held-out
restaurants openings
and closings in the data.
But we see that
the standard deviations are
really big for the actuals,
and so you're not
really going to be
able to tell that your model has
performed well by how well
it fits these actuals.
So, this was a proof
of concept paper,
and so now we get a sense
of the power calculation.
We need to do
many more cities and
a longer time period in order
to get these error bars
down to be a meaningful level
where we could say one model is
better than another model at
doing those
counter-factuals. Yeah.
>> So, one question is,
what is the reference
point to which
these distances are
defined at [inaudible].
During lunchtime and what
location it matter more then?
>> Yes. So, I'm using
your morning location.
So, I only pick users that
are in the same place
every morning and I use
their morning location. Yeah.
>> Could you go back
a couple slides to
the coefficients and
standard errors.
So, just looking at this, one
thing that I see
jumps out at me is
these coefficients are
very similar across
cities and the standard errors
are all very small.
What that suggests to me is
there's a lot of shrinkage of
individual effects
being shrunk to
a common effect
that's going on here.
I'm wondering if you can say
something about exactly what
that parameter is
a Bayesian model,
and how it will identify
it it isn't if perhaps-
>> Yes. So, actually
these are not parameters.
These we didn't actually
put in city in the model.
This is just as aggregating
the data after the fact.
But it's suggesting that we
maybe don't have enough data,
or it could just
suggest that people are
similar and how far
they're willing to drive.
>> Yeah. There was not how
to determine the model.
You're learning
an overall category
of elasticity and that
varies across types of
people and their shrinkage
that perhaps it's shrinking
those elasticities
across different types
of people to a common mean.
A lot of shrinkage is being
applied when you're
ending up with.
>> Exactly. So, I think
one of my takeaways from
say this project is
that you're actually do
need quite a bit of data.
So, seeing people go
to 12 restaurants
maybe you need
more data than that,
because the priors
can still matter.
Also having hundreds of
experiments isn't that helpful if
those experiments
are really noisy.
So, I need thousands and
thousands of experiments
not hundreds in order
to pin things down.
Because what really varying in
the model is that people's
choice sets are changing.
But there's not
enormous amount of
that going on here in
this prototype. Yeah.
>> Maybe this is saying
a simillar thing.
But on the previous slide,
you attributed the reversal
of the direction to
the small sample size.
But the coefficients
were still statistically
different from each other.
>> Yeah. No, no. I
don't have to attribute
that to the small sample size.
I would attribute
that to we don't
have exogenous variation
in those things.
So, it could be proxying
for something else.
So, I don't think if
those as causal effects.
If I really wanted
to know the effect
of those price things
and I would want to run
an experiment where
the same restaurant
changed its price, but
I don't have that.
So, expensive restaurants are
better in some other way.
So, yeah.
>> I missed this, the denominator
of the multinomial model.
Are you thinking of
the entire universe
of items or are you
thinking of somehow
modeling what are
the items the user might
have been exposed to?
>> So, in practice
we cut it a bit.
But we look in within 12 miles.
So, each users got
hundreds of choices.
So, in an online setting,
you might imagine
modeling that exposure,
and that's actually
my original project.
This whole thing was
supposed to be for
using Internet Explorer to
look at people's news behavior.
But we still haven't gotten to
that project yet because we're
building up one thing
at the time.
Actually, I think now
we're ready to do that.
Actually, our code
can accommodate that.
But then there's
more modeling decisions
to make about exactly how
you think about what
the users are exposed to and
what order they're
in and so on. Yeah.
>> There were
a couple of location
papers out there that say
another reason that
people pick places
to go is because
their friends have
chosen the place
and they just want
to go on with your friends.
So, does your original
location data
let you model that effect?
>> I would love to do that.
This type of location data,
I'm getting people's pinging
a couple of times a day.
So, you just really can't do
like you are at the same places
as other person.
When I first heard about
the data I was like oh
there's all these cool things
I see this person is
here with this other person
and I'm going to look at
their networks. It's not
really good at that.
It's good at counting things
that where you go and you
stay there for a long time.
It just very noisy.
If I think of I would like to
ideally I mean you can
forgetting about privacy
of course from
a research perspective
it would be nice if I
could see everybody
where they are
continuously all day long
that the status is very,
very far from that.
Google has that data
from their from
their phones but I don't,
and that's not enough to get
me to go work at Google.
I don't think anybody has
published on that data.
Because I think people
thought a little bit
about it that might be make
them a little nervous.
Okay. So, all right,
then one of the things we
look at is we compare.
Why I showed you the picture
but it's a little bit noisy,
how we do relative to
the actuals. Let's see.
Let me just show a few pictures
what some of the types of
things you can do you can
say if I want to think about
a restaurant category in what
parts are user preferences
such that they
relatively more like a category.
So, let me come
down to Vietnamese.
Vietnamese is very strong in
the South San Jose which is
corresponds to where
there's population.
We can also ask sets
where Vietnamese is
relatively popular relative to
other places that
Vietnamese as like.
We can also ask if I pick
the location what would be
the best category
for that location.
So, if I actually took
this restaurant while I put in
another restaurant of a different
category what would
be the choice?
We make that choice among
relatively similar things.
So, we can see here this
is where salad is good,
and this is where
burgers is good.
If I look only among
Asian restaurants,
Vietnamese is great here,
further up the peninsula people
are more partial to Chinese,
and then there's a Japanese
preference section in here.
So, this type of model could
be used in one reason that
the SafeGraph and Yelp
are interested in
this with this is actually
a use case for their data,
that people are trying to
figure out where
to locate stores.
So, if you understand
people's preferences you can
think about this counterfactual.
You can understand better who are
your competitors and
what would you do.
So, that's basically just
to sum up this paper,
the first paper here I would say
the least tight of
the papers in terms of
the causal identification of
saying have I really told you
that I'm sure that I
didn't put tangled distance
from other things.
But on the other hand,
we do see users making
choices in users and
we see restaurants
opening and closing.
So, I have some confidence
that I'm learning and then
I'm trying to pose
here whether or not
I've completely estimated
the parameters correctly.
Also illustrating the
counterfactuals that you would like
to do assuming that you
didn't have those parameters.
So, the reason to get
these structural parameters
whether or not you think
I've done it perfectly,
is to do these counterfactuals.
So, the research agenda
is then to find
datasets where you can
learn them as well as build
better models to answer
these questions. Yeah.
>> So, in this best
restaurant categories
try to understand how
the models being interpreted.
Is it the case that
you want to place
a restaurant in a location
where the people
like that category but there are
no other things event
category rounds so I place
a Vietnamese restaurant in
a place where there are
no Vietnamese restaurants but
people are willing to
travel distance for that?
Or am placing it around
other things of a similar type.
So, for example you
place a coffee shop next
to Starbucks because
everybody learns that you
filter out some of their
actual market that way. Which?
>> I guess like in the absence of
this model then you
would have to reason
about all of those things.
What we actually do is
we just simulate and
because this is where you really
get the power of
the economic model.
I mean it's a very
simple economic model,
the power of optimization.
We're assuming we understand
consumer's preferences,
and we're assuming
that each consumer
solves an optimization problem.
That means if I change
the choice set,
I can just have
each consumer reoptimize.
So, we're literally running
a simulation where we
reoptimize for for each consumer
and we come up counterfactually
with what they would've chosen.
Then I could post process
that and try to explain why?
Like I could go back and
say why is it salad here?
I could look at well,
it's salad here because
there's actually not a lot of
salad places there and there's
an unserved demand for salad?
Or is it salads here because
the people here have really
strong preferences for salad?
You could try to go back and
post-process and explain
why you got this answer.
But this is just
coming literally from
simulating and assuming you have
the user preferences correct.
>> Can you get
all the [inaudible] that you
are putting in the model?
Like is it possible for
you to construct them?
For instance you wouldn't
know until you open
a restaurant what's your ratings
going to be. right, so.
>> Well, so I think you would.
Yes. So, the weakness
of this is that I said
earlier I don't give
these things complete
causal interpretations and now
I just did a counter-factual,
I did give them
causal interpretation.
So, take it with a grain of salt.
But I think what you
would think about
the positioning is you
would say I'm in a position
in a restaurant and I'm going to
hire a good chef and
I know that I need
to be in this category
in order to succeed.
You could roughly say if
there's unobservables around
the location I need to be
comparable to the things
that are in the category.
So, if Chinese is proxying
for a quiet location to
have a business meeting,
then you would want to make
your Chinese restaurant like
other Chinese restaurants,
and if you made
your Chinese restaurant
different from other
Chinese restaurants and it
wasn't a great place to go with
your colleagues for lunch
then you might fail.
So, we haven't fully
uncovered the production
function for the restaurant.
There's omitted variables.
So, that's the part that's not as
completely clean.
Actually guys this is.
Let me let me actually move
on to the other papers if you
don't mind unless somebody
has something super pressing.
Okay. So, because I think
the next papers
actually get more and
more interesting, and yeah.
Okay. So, let me now
go to shopping data.
So, here we have
a dataset that was constructed
by some other people.
I actually originally procured
the data but then they
wrote this really nice
paper with it where
they found a single
isolated grocery store
and they cleaned
up the data for
all loyalty club shoppers at
that single isolated store
over an 18 month period,
and they went through
and actually did
a bunch of coding to figure
out out of stock data at
approximately the hourly level,
so they could figure out if
a product when out of stock.
We also in the store,
all the prices changed
on Tuesday night.
So, and the nice thing
about Tuesday night,
and I think this is partly
why they picked it,
is that Tuesday and Wednesday are
very similar shopping days.
They're indistinguishable in
terms of what people buy.
Friday is different,
Monday is different,
nighttime is different
than daytime
even for the same consumer.
But roughly Tuesday
and Wednesday are
very similar days in
terms of how people shop.
Then we have the product
hierarchy for this.
So, in the first paper
we're going to
use the observed
product hierarchy.
So, I know the UPC and
all these different
categorizations of the product.
In the second paper
on the same dataset,
I'm going to throw this away
and I'm going to try to
infer those things from
the choice behavior.
So, we look at users who had
at least 20 shopping trips
on Tuesday or
Wednesday with
more than 10 items per trip.
We started with
the top 235 categories.
So, a category will
be like tomatoes
or toilet paper or yogurt.
We throw out things
where people basically
only bought one product.
There's somethings like
frozen dinners where all of
the products in the category
have prices that move together.
It's like all the frozen
dinners are expensive
one week and they're cheap
the next week. So,
we threw those out.
So, we only kept categories where
people bought
different products from
the categories and where
there was independent
variation in the price,
because here now I'm going to
try to be a little bit more
rigorous on the causal
identification.
So, I ended up with
2,000 consumers,
123 categories, 1,263 items,
and 333,000 trips and rather
than do cross-validation,
because the models are
expensive to compute,
we just have a single
validation set. Yap.
>> [inaudible] How are
the prices change?
>> Who changes them?
Or what are they
thinking about when
they change them?
Yeah, that's a
little complicated.
It can be because
manufacturer costs change
sometimes or it could be because
the store decided to do it.
Ultimately the chain often
decides at the chain level.
But something you might
be concerned about
is on some weeks,
going from Tuesday
to Wednesday you
might raise the price because
Thursday is Thanksgiving,
and so we're going to do some
testing and actually throw
out products that have
that kind of a problem.
So, let me show you how we
do the testing for that.
So, this is a price series,
this is a typical price series
for a single UPC.
This is what a price series
looks like for
the average prices for a
category mainstream white bread.
So, we do see that there can
be like systematic trends in
those prices but there's also
like once you look across
all the prices there's actually
a fair bit of price variation.
In most categories there's
a price change most weeks.
So, we do actually have
a lot of if you think of
each price change
as an experiment,
we have a lot of experiments.
If we want to think about
identifying assumption,
we're basically going to say that
the counterfactual
distribution of
purchases between Tuesday and
Wednesday in weeks with
price changes can be
constructed from their behavior
on the weeks without
price changes.
So, what we're going to do
is we're basically
going to control,
we're going to have dummies
for each week and category.
So, we're basically
going to learn
how popular this product
is this week or
this category is in this week
and then we're also
going to learn how different
Tuesday and Wednesday are.
It turns out they're not
actually different so that's not
very important but we
control for that anyways.
So, essentially
what we're going to
assume is that if I tell
you how popular this week
is and I tell you whether
to Tuesday or Wednesday,
I can figure out what would have
happened if the price
hadn't changed.
So, that's a functional
form assumption,
but we think it's a pretty
good one in the sense that
in most products in most weeks
Tuesday and Wednesday or
pretty much the same.
But, we're not going
to just accept that,
we're going to do what
we call a Placebo test.
Now, this is not a definitive
test, it's just suggestive.
But it maybe provide you
some competence and it also
gives you a way to
kick things out.
So, we use this to kick out
stone fruits for example.
Turns out peaches are
really seasonal and
so there's some things
that flunk the test
I'm going to do.
So, what we're going to do
is create fake price series,
we're going to shift
the price series
forward or back in time,
and then we're going to estimate
the model with fake price series,
and if there was
an ongoing trend, so,
the prices are all
going up and also
demand is going up
at the same time,
then it would look like there was
a price change even in weeks
where there weren't
a price change.
So, we're testing for
a certain type of
problem in our model.
What we do is we estimate
a simple multinomial logit model
and we get the coefficients
on price and we
want to look at this is what
the price shifts look like
and we want to look at
the distribution of the P-values
on the price coefficient.
So, in particular, if
these prices were
just random noise,
then the P-values on
the price coefficient should
be uniformly distributed.
There should be no effect
of a noisy price series,
and so we should see a uniform
distribution of P-values.
This red is the
actual distribution
of P-values with
the actual price series,
which is saying that
most of the time
we think that there's
a significantly negative
effect of the price.
But with the fake price series,
they look roughly uniform
although not perfectly uniform,
and we're arguing
that this sort of
validates that are given
all the controls we put in
that the prices that our
assumption is good and then if
not there's some other time trend
going on that we haven't
captured in our model.
We're not testing
every alternative,
we're just testing alternatives
about gradual shifts,
up or gradual shifts down
in a product's popularity.
So, I'd say this type
of Placebo test
is been used in economics
but not usually it's scale,
like we usually do
much simpler versions of
these and I would
say that there's
some interesting ideas of
bringing these kinds of
tests into machine learning
settings where we have
lots of experiments,
and that idea I think we do
it in a very small
hand tuning way.
Suppose there was
a minimum wage change in 1984,
we see or would we think
that the minimum wage would
change in 1983 if the model
says that it looks like there was
an effect of a change that didn't
happen then we reject our model.
But it's usually one change in
one year not lots
of little changes.
Okay. So, if we say we
throw out some things
and this works,
then let me go on to our model.
So, our model like before,
we're going to have
user utilities,
they're going to have
factorized mean utilities.
Now instead of
distance we have price
and we're going to have
factorized price coefficients.
Again, this model is going to
say here conditional on
purchasing in a category,
you have a multinomial
logit form.
But we're we're going to add to
our previous model is
the nested logit formulation,
which has proved
to be very popular
and fits very well in economics.
So, the problem is
that if I included
the outside good
which is not buying
anything in this model,
the assumption that
the errors are
IID is actually
a really bad assumption,
because some days you're
going to go to the store
and you really need paper
towels and so there's
a correlated positive shock
for all the paper towels and
not buying a paper towel
is a separate option.
So what the nested logit
basically assumes
is that first you
choose buy a product or not buy
a product and then you choose
what to buy in the category.
And technically, it
allows for correlation in
these errors across
all the products
other than don't buy.
But a certain form
of correlation,
and the nice thing about
the nested logic
from a computational
perspective is that
you can actually
estimate it as is two
sequential multinomial logits.
So, it's more efficient
to jointly estimate them.
So, likes data in R, will
jointly estimate them,
but because I have
a very complicated
computational problem
with all my latent variables,
I'm going to estimate
them sequentially which
loses something but it works.
So, first, I'm going to model
this multinomial logit with
all my latent variables
and then I'm going to
model the choice of whether
to buy anything at all.
There's going to
be a factorization
of the choice, Don't
buy anything at all.
So, it's a proof,
it's like a page of algebra.
You can show that if you put in
the utilities for all of
the other items in the category,
that's called the
inclusive value,
using this crazy
functional form here,
inclusive value is log of
the sum of e to the Us,
then you will get
the parameters of
the user's utility function.
So, I won't show you
that proof but that was
part of [inaudible] work in
the early 70s was to do
this algebra which turned
out to be very
convenient algebra.
So, now, I'm going to do
a two-stage estimation.
First, I'll do this model,
get all the parameters,
figure out the utilities,
then I take the utilities,
construct the inclusive value
of just buying something,
and then I can do
another multinomial logit
to choose between buying
something and buying nothing.
That allows for
the correlation and it's
very important for fitting
shopping data because
most consumers don't purchase,
so those zeros are really
important in the data,
and this is something
other people have
observed in machine
learning as well,
trying to model the zeros is
really important for
modeling trace data.
Okay, we also use
Bayesian inference again,
and so, I'm just here to
show you a few things,
this actually was
just a total pain in the ass,
but we compared a zillion
different common economic models
and we win,
otherwise I wouldn't be
showing you the slide.
So, the thing that's more
interesting, I would say,
that we found is that we actually
focus on how we do in
terms of counterfactuals.
This is all weeks,
this is weeks where
one of the products in the
category is out of stock,
this is weeks where one of
the products has a price change,
and I'm only looking at
your purchases of the product
that had a price change,
and this is observations
where another product in the
category had a price change,
and I'm looking at purchases of
the product that didn't
have the price change.
So, these are all
different counterfactuals,
and so we actually end up finding
different model selection
if we tune for,
say, the price change
counterfactual rather than overall.
So, it's important to tune
your model for your goal and
counterfactual will put more
of a weight on trying to
understand the role of
the price changes while,
otherwise, you might put
more role work into
the mean utility.
So then, some of the things
that we get out of that,
we used data about
categories but we
didn't use about
subcategories which are
called classes or subclasses.
So, within water, there's
sparkling water and then there's
flavored sparkling water is
a subclass, that's
just an example.
So, what we find is
that our model does
a better job at understanding
what's in the same class.
So, we find much higher
cross-price elasticity,
so the impact of
one product's price on
another product within
a class than across classes.
So, we understand that
sparkling waters are
better substitutes
than flat water and
sparkling water in a way
that the other models can't.
Okay. So, it's not
quite done yet,
this is the first project,
we started this three years ago,
but we have continued.
First, we had to make
all these changes,
we had to add
the nested logit and
this functional form and the way
we brought in
the co-variants and so on.
Then now, what we're
finishing is doing
personalized pricing and
couponing strategies using this.
Relative to the
economics literature,
we spend a lot of time showing
how pooling information
across users and
items really adds a lot of value.
So, one of the things,
if I just study lettuce,
you don't buy lettuce
that much and there's
not many price
changes for lettuce.
But if I understand that
your price sensitivity
for lettuce
is similar to your price
sensitivity for tomatoes,
and I understand
that tomatoes and
lettuce have
common latent factors,
then even if I don't see
you buy tomatoes very much,
I can learn about
your price sensitivity for
tomatoes from your price
sensitivity for lettuce.
So that cross-product learning
allows you to get a lot
more out of a dataset
where people don't purchase
things very often.
So, most consumers
purchase most products,
like, one percent of the time,
so I think that's
going to be also like
a common theme if you
think about other types of
browsing and online data where
most consumers don't do
most things very often.
Now, at some level, that insight,
you guys already knew that
because that's the insight of
the Netflix composition and
matrix factorization so you're,
like, "What took you so long?"
In economics, we didn't.
Nobody tried it so we're
showing them that that works.
So, I think the benefit relative
to the machine learning
literature for
this is that actually,
there were a large number
of computational tweaks we needed
to get to get this
to run at scale.
Once you put in
the multinomial logit form,
we have the softmax and
then non-linear and we have
these structural parameters,
so that was the part of
the computational thing,
really, embedding it in
the utility
maximization framework.
Now, I want to talk
about the last paper
which in some sense is
the most innovative
computationally,
although I'll go back to
a little bit of apologizing
because I would
say that the model is good
but it's not the final model.
So, in this paper,
we've got the same dataset,
basically the same problem,
but now I want to throw away
my item information and say,
"I don't know how these products
relate to each other,
and further, I want to
allow that some of them
are actually complements."
So, the old model
said, "Paper, towels,
and tomatoes are just completely
separate. They don't
affect each other."
Then we further
assumed you're only
going to choose one paper towel,
you're only going to
choose one kind of tomato,
and we threw away things
where you bought a lot,
like multiple varieties of
yogurt, we actually
threw away yogurt.
Now, we're going to
ask a question like
"Can I figure out that
hotdogs and buns go together?
Actually, could I
figure out that even
though water and juice are
in different categories,
those are actually also
imperfect substitutes.
Can I learn all of
that from the data?"
So, I actually started
working on this problem in
1995 and I solved it for
two choices and then we
gave up because we
weren't able to go
beyond three or four
computationally in the 90s.
Of course, if I had met all
of you guys in the 90s,
there were those of you who
are still alive as scholars,
you probably could have
helped me at that time
but you weren't born yet
as scholars in the 90s.
But it was still a hard problem.
So, we studied this and
that the paper came out,
it's actually
a pretty well-cited paper,
but we stopped with
three or four choices.
So, let me actually just
skip over that picture,
I'll just tell you that there was
a very small [inaudible]
listed every economics paper
that's ever tried
to estimate complementarity
between two or three things
and they've maxed out
at three roughly.
So, I've got three choices
and I'm going to see,
basically there's
two to the three,
there's eight bundles,
and I'm going to try
to understand your preferences
for those eight bundles.
But of course, these things get
very complicated very fast.
If I wanted to go back and
think I have 5,000 choices,
there's a question of, like,
"Well, wait a second.
Not only is this
hard to compute for
me but how the heck could
the consumer do it?"
I'm using a utility
maximization framework and I'm
trying to infer what
the consumer was doing.
When they maximized, there
were two to the 5,000 bundles,
but isn't that idiotic?
At some level, right?
They can't really do that.
So, the approach
we're going to take
in this paper is
we're going to impose
an arbitrary heuristic on how
the consumers shop
and then try to
use that and estimate the
parameters of that heuristic.
The problem with that is why my
heuristic and not somebody
else's heuristic.
I would say, "Yeah,
that's a problem."
But I'm going to see if I get
sensible things out of it.
Okay. So, what we're going to do
is we're going to make
a behavioral assumption.
So, when I say this, this
is not the last version,
we have a bunch of
extensions that are
in progress on this.
But the basic behavioral
assumption is
a myopic consumer
goes into the store,
considers sequentially
what to buy,
and they're going to go in
order of importance basically.
So, we're going to start with
the thing that's highest
in their utility from
everything in the store.
They're going to put
that into their basket
and then they're going
to say, "All right.
What should I do next?"
Then they're going to put
the next thing in the basket.
But when they put
the next thing in the basket,
they're going to consider
what's already in their basket.
So, if they have
hotdog buns in the basket,
they're going to consider
that when they buy hotdogs.
Furthermore, there's going
to be a look-ahead model.
So, the consumer is going to
look ahead to the next item.
For now, I have them look
ahead to the whole store,
although you can
imagine it's better for
them to go sequentially
through sections of
the store or to think about
things that go together.
But anyways, they're going
to look right now and say,
"I'm going to look ahead to
the next item accounting
for the potential
complimentarity."
Of course, you might want to look
ahead two or three steps.
Now, hopefully, a lot
of you are thinking,
"Sounds like
reinforcement learning."
Yeah, exactly. So, this
is fun and this is
a connection that I'd
like to further develop.
Okay. Then there's
a latent item ordering
because they don't actually know
what order they put
things in the basket,
but this behavioral model
implies a likelihood over orders,
conditional on what
you purchased,
there's all likelihood over that
orders if you followed
that behavioral model.
So, I can actually infer
that latent variable as well,
and it's basically because
higher value item should
have been purchased earlier.
So, this is our model.
So, we still have the same
functional form of utility,
we're still going to
have logit errors,
each end they make a choice.
But now, we're assuming
this is possible for
complementarity in
this Look-Ahead Model.
So, in the paper we write
down what this means for
the Probabilistic Model.
Okay. So, they just to get
a sense of how this works,
this is simulated data.
So, we're going to compare here
a Myopic Model where you
just go to the store,
you don't think ahead
to Think-Ahead model.
We generated data about
purchases from
all these products,
and we generated them according
to preferences that
are what you'd think.
So, hotdogs and hotdog buns
are complements.
What turns out in the data,
is it diapers and
coffee are highly
positively correlated?
I should pause there actually
because that everybody
hears from economics.
So, there's this distinction
between correlation and
complementarity which we think
about a lot in economics,
but maybe those words
are almost used
interchangeably if you're not
used to thinking about it.
So, we would say that coffee
and diapers are complements.
If you lower the price of coffee,
you would buy more coffee
and you'd buy more diapers,
that means their compliments
because they go together.
When you buy coffee
you want more diapers,
when you buy diapers,
you buy more coffee.
Similarly, if you raise
the price of coffee,
you would buy less diapers.
Okay. If they are correlated,
it just means there might be
something about people that
makes them like
coffee and diapers,
but if you go out
of stock on coffee,
you won't skip the diapers.
Okay. So, that's actually
a really important thing
because there's
lots of stuff in the
data that's correlated,
and a simple just
matrix factorization
won't be able to tell if
just coffee and diapers go
together because you need
coffee to enjoy diapers,
or if they go together because
Sleepless people with babies
need a lot of coffee.
So, those things you can't tell
the difference and just
the matrix
factorization approach.
How could you possibly
tell the difference?
Will you need data where
the diapers bought a stock,
or the diapers price goes
up or the diapers
price goes down?
You actually have to measure
whether when the price goes down,
people respond in
the other product,
and that's the key
identification strategy here.
So, in this simulation,
these up arrows show
we estimated a model,
and then we predicted
what would happen if we
predict onto a test set that has
higher than usual
prices of coffee,
and higher than usual
prices of taco shells.
So, this is in
the not-think-head model and
this is in the think-ahead model.
So, we see in
the not-think-ahead model,
the Myopic Model, when you raise
the prices of taco shells,
you still predict that
people buy taco seasoning
because they're going to go
and look for the taco seasoning,
but they're not going
to look think-ahead,
that the taco shells
are too expensive,
and so they don't want
the taco seasoning.
But in the look-ahead model,
when the taco shells
are expensive,
the model predicts that people
won't buy taco seasoning either,
because they look ahead and
they understand that they're not
going to buy the taco
shells. So, yeah?
>> So, I feel like this example
points out to me that
the likelihood function
is going to be
independence latent
order that you're
not going to observe. Right.
>> Yeah, so you would,
you infer it but it's,
the behavioral model implies
a probability distribution
over orderings,
but if we had a different
behavioral model,
we can't tell the difference
between the different behavioral
models from the data,
except for like by
broad goodness of fit measures.
>> So, I guess I didn't,
I still feel like
there's going to
be touching identification
problems here.
I can't tell the difference
between one unobserved
ordering and
whatnot observes that have
preferences for different items
are boring, and
a different observation.
>> The price variation and out of
stock variation sufficiently
should pin everything down,
but I'm not going to
argue that I have
that much price variation
in my data set.
>> Going to the store where
things actually are
geographically,
and see if that lines
up with your line.
>> Yeah. I mean, I
think if you really
wanted to get into
that level of detail,
it would be good to have
online browsing data
so that you could
actually observe
the consumers behavior.
So, let me just show you
a couple of other quick things.
So, here because
we published this,
republishing the center between
machine learning audience and
not to economics audience,
we have a lot less
descriptive statistics.
But here we show that
our model does well,
and what we do, instead
of the other model
where the other paper where we
held out days with price changes,
here we're just going
to look at subsets of
test data that have
different prices,
20 percent, 30 percent
and we show that our model of
the relative performance
of our model it
gets better when we get to
the more extreme prices,
and these are different versions
of models that
David Blei has used like
hierarchical Poisson
factorization and
various embedding models
that he's used from text.
So, he's showing that relative
to David state of the art,
machine learning embedding models
incorporating
the price information in
the complementarity
end does better
when the prices are
different than average,
and that's what you're hoping
because we want to do well
predicting in unusual settings.
So then, this is
what we discover.
So again, I told the model now
nothing about what the products
were, just the UPCs,
and we do things like
we discovered cheese,
and we discovered baking,
and we discovered fruit,
and we discovered toilet paper.
So, that's lovely. So,
we can basically figure
out what the products are as
well as what substitutes.
So, just here, the last slide,
I want to give some examples of
the things you can do here.
Here we're going
to query the data.
So, if we query mission
tortillas soft tacos,
we can see which items
are the most
complimentary according to
our estimated user preferences
with mission tortilla soft taco.
We find taco shells,
taco seasoning, and taco mix,
taco seasoning mix are
those complimentary with
top tacos, hot dog buns,
yeah, they are also complimentary
with these other hot dog buns
which we then could think about,
maybe there's
a taste for variety.
Mustard is complementary with
hamburger buns and so on.
So, I tell my kids
that I worked for
three years, and
at the end of it,
I discovered that they mustered
goes with hamburger buns.
So, at some level
like this is not
the deepest scientific discovery
you'd ever want to make.
But the idea would be that if you
think if you're Amazon or eBay,
and you have these really
big product assortments,
and you don't really
know what kinds of
things compete with each other
and what kinds of
things go together,
this could be helpful.
In particular, utilizing
one particular time can
be a problem because,
you give a sale on one product
and it looks like
you're doing great,
but you've actually
stolen the demand from
another product or similarly,
you have a sale on
one product and you're not,
you're underestimating
the benefit of
getting people to buy
more of another product.
So, those types of
counterfactuals are interesting.
So just to conclude, I would say,
I hope I've communicated
effectively,
that this is all a work
in progress.
The goal I hope was clear that we
want to be able to do
these kinds of counterfactuals.
The challenges maybe are clear,
that it's actually hard
to convince people,
that you've really identified
the structural parameters
through counterfactuals.
That's not just because I'm Liem,
it's because it's hard
to find data that
actually has enough variation
to figure this stuff out.
But if you have
big datasets and you
do have price changes and
you do have out of stock,
then you start to learn
enough to make this better.
So, I would say
the bigger research agenda
bringing together ideas from
reinforcement learning,
in inverse
in matrix factorization
and econometrics,
is to be able to help
companies as well as
like customers of Azure,
and others be able to
make these decisions.
>> Your kids have been shocked
to find that three years
[inaudible].
All right.
Okay, some questions. Yeah.
>> Yes. So, did you do any
during holdout foundation.
Are you would you trying to
validate on the back door?
>> So, I think
that if one thing I would
love to see change,
is if the Machine
Learning audiences,
I feel often don't have
a lot of patients for
30 or 40 pages of
empirical analysis.
But in the paper we have aimed
for the marketing journal,
we spend more time trying
to do these holdout sets
and really identify,
here's days that we held
out data from consumers in
weeks where there were
price changes and then we
evaluated ourselves on how we fit
for those consumers
on those weeks.
So, yes. So, the goal
is to tune and
evaluate yourself on held-out
data on weeks with changes.
It's that, so normally
the process would just
be hold out data,
how do we predict.
Is it any different than saying,
"Well, now we have to hold out.
Hold out experiments
or counterfactuals,
or is it basically
just that simple,
or there are more things that you
consider when you
are trying to.".
Well, so I think there's
a couple of things
first of all you'd
like to hold out
experiments, absolutely.
In some sense, you want
the experiments to be
representative of the ones
that you would do,
and they need to be different
from what's in your data.
But so, that's the first
differences and you
want to make sure that
you're testing changes.
The second is what's
your test statistic,
because if my question is
I want to raise the price
for all consumers,
then my test statistic
should be something about
predicting overall who bought
this product on this day.
That's actually more
aggregated test statistic,
and you actually make a different
bias-variance trade off for that.
Then if I said, "Oh,
what I want to do is send
personalized coupons,
then my test statistic
would be about
individual responses
to price changes,
and then you would make
a different
bias-variance trade-off.
So, one of the things
we weren't really
thinking about going in,
we were thinking about
just prediction versus
counterfactual.
Then we surprised ourselves,
because it all let's just
starts by tuning for prediction,
it will be pretty similar,
but it was actually
very different numbers of
latent variables and so on
depending on whether you
wanted an aggregate test
statistic or a more micro one.
So, that's actually a little bit
unsatisfying though,
because it says you have to
know the question you're asking,
answering to choose a model,
and it's harder to make
a general purpose model.
>> Yeah, I get it.
>> Can you go through what
this numbers are again
just because it looks
like private brand hamburger buns
are top three complements,
and top three substitutes.
>> Yes. So, this is
not substitutes,
this is something we
call the exchangability.
So, it turns out that it
was actually very hard to
identify substitutes
in data like this,
because basically most stuff
it's just never purchased.
So, it's hard to tell
that two things,
they're substitutes versus
you just never bought them.
So, what we actually introduced
a new concept which we call,
I mean it's not exchangability
is on new concept,
but as applied here,
what we said two things are
exchangeable if they're
into pairwise interactions with
all other products are the same.
There's two reasons things
could be exchangeable.
If they're always
bought together,
they would have the same pairwise
interactions with everybody.
If they are never
bought together,
they would have the same pairwise
interactions with everybody.
So, then the idea is that if we
take things that are
exchangeable and they're
not compliments,
maybe those are substitutes.
Because just empirically,
we got a bunch of
new ways trying to
identify substitutes.
That gets back to
modelling the zeros.
So, another part of
our research agenda
is to have better modeling
of the zeros which might help
us hone in on substitutes
a little bit more.
>> It might help.
>> Yes, this remark
you made about
basically different
matrix leading to
different parameters
being selected was one.
I guess when I saw that earlier,
it made me a little bit
nervous in the sense
that so you're lying
to some degree on,
you're getting some reasonably
good parameter identification
to make the predictions right,
you're not just relying
on having good predictive
accuracy from the model.
To me if the answer
is changing based on
the question you're asking,
that to some degree
revealing that there
is non-identifiability going
on with the parameters,
and so you're you're
not learning quite
the best ones you
can from the data.
>> Let me speak that. That's
a deep, deep question.
So, I think in economics,
this is probably why I think
people are going to have
some mixed reactions to this
or they are generally more,
I thought people might hate it.
In economics, they
actually liking it better
than I thought, but there's some.
It's a real weighted
different way
of thinking about things.
We used to think there is
one true structural preference,
and I'm going to learn it,
and my theorem has to be
when angle to infinity,
I'll learn it,
I nail it, I get
precise confidence intervals,
I know your preferences.
Some level like that just here,
I mean how can I
really know what you
feel about lettuce when I saw
you buy lettuce three times.
So, I think there is a benefit
to the Machine
Learning perspective,
which is it's all
an approximation,
and I just want to have
a better approximation.
So, that is a slightly
more pragmatic
engineering approach,
but you can only
operationalize it if you have
a test set that
says how well do I do
it what I care about,
which then in some sense requires
you to have held out experiments.
Because if I can't, if
exactly as you say,
there are many models that
would equally fit the data.
It's not they're not identified
whether you have
10 latent factors,
or 50, or 70.
I don't know which one it is,
but I want to know what's
the best approximation
to your preferences for
the purpose of doing a
certain counter-factual.
But it's very unappealing that
you have a different model
for different questions.
But it may be a fact of nature,
but it's an unfortunate
fact of nature
because having too many degrees
of freedom in the hands
of the analyst
and so on, can be problematic.
>> Before we go on.
>> I'll say for folks that pursue
facts of nature that they're
looking for the model.
You want to know what's
really going on,
and that's different
than user having
a predictive model or a task,
or a counter-factual model
you can actually use in practice.
So, it's different between
the foundations of
science sometimes.
I think that's where it
gets a little bit
deeper here, right.
>> Yeah, no it's a very yeah.
I think that our search for
the ground truth of what
people's preferences are
was a very honorable search,
but what do I do if I
have to make a decision,
and I haven't seen
you 10,000 times with
10,000 different prices
for for lettuce,
and so then I want to have
a good approximation to that.
So, I think we have
to, I guess we
collectively are going
to have to figure out
how to marry these approaches
and make ourselves stay
rigorous without just saying
what the economist
said until today,
was I just can't try to
answer those questions.
>> Oh, we finished out.
>> Oh sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
So, if we just take two
more I know we can make it
like discussions around
the foot area there.
So, Maggie and.
>> So, my question is
about, you were going
to talk before.
>> My question's really short.
So, you mentioned something along
the lines of statisticians and
econometricians are
hesitant to take on
variational inferences like
a method of proximity inference.
Do you get the sense of like,
"Why is this
salutation happening,
what could possibly be
done to combat that,
and have new curve. "
For example, with
variational inference,
everything you are
taking derivatives,
so it's like it's
optimization based.
So, you can actually test like
sensitivity to your priors,
things like that.
So, I think it'd be
more confidence there.
>> Sure. I think it's really
just that it's moving away,
at the end because
you know you're
getting approximation at the end,
you have to I mean.
For computational reasons
you made a lot of
independence assumptions
which you don't really buy,
then at some level
you're having to
acknowledge the truth which
was always there to start with,
which is that my model
is an approximation,
and I haven't actually
really found the ground
truth of nature.
Along with that
acknowledging that,
then you need to add in
all this other stuff like,
"How do I test the model,
how do I evaluate the model which
brings in a lot of ambiguity?"
So, the world where we could
prove that we were
going to discover
the true laws of nature and
eventually converge
to it exactly,
didn't open up
these cans of work.
Now in practice that you cut off
the Markov Chain Monte Carlo
after a month,
and did it converge, did it not?
I made 10,000 other assumptions
so that I could actually
make my Markov-chain
Monte-Carlo run in a month,
and I assumed this was linear and
now so I made all these
other assumptions.
So, it's very
schizophrenic because
I made a zillion assumptions,
but then I said "I
found the truth."
While I say that I feel like
the Machine Learning approach
is a little more
like it's all an approximation,
I'm going to admit that I
can't figure out the truth,
and then I'm going to
focus a lot more on
testing and documenting
the performance.
That's just harder for
counter-factual inference,
but I say it's not impossible.
But I think my results today mix,
like "Are you
completely convinced
that I got exactly
the right parameters?
No, you shouldn't be"
or "Do you think that
maybe you could if you
had a great enough
dataset hopefully."
>> Great. The last question
of the open questions.
>> I was going to ask,
there was a example
that one of my mentors used to
bring on as the first
slide which was,
"If you have a laptop
and a backpack
is suggested as a suggestion".
That's, when you are
planning to buy a laptop,
that's a reasonable suggestion,
but if you're buying
backpack for laptop,
then suggesting
laptop seems stupid.
That relates to
the order question,
but also is a causal question,
and I'm wondering if
your model actually in
any way it's able
to recover that,
and be suggestive
about bar graph.
>> I would say we made
an assumption there.
So, we assumed you were
going to start with
the highest utility things
first which could be
maybe it works with
the laptop and then the
backpack, and actually we.
But that's by assumption,
we didn't discover,
that we assumed it.
Maybe it may be
actually a bunch of
these silly examples have
that same feature that you start
with the most important thing,
but we don't learn it,
and I think it would be
interesting to learn it,
but if I wanted to learn that,
I wouldn't treat it all
as a big latent variable,
I would actually get data
from an online shopping.
So, I could actually observe
it, I could just think it.
At the point you're
trying to model at
that level of detail,
you should get the data.
>> Okay, well thanks
very much for taking.